>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David Plylar: Hi everybody.
Welcome to what promises to be
an exciting afternoon of music
by Milton Babbitt and
Arnold Schoenberg.
My name is David Plylar.
It is my pleasure to introduce
our guest lecturer today,
whose articles, books,
and lectures have made
significant contributions
to our understandings
of his subjects.
Walter Frisch is the H.
Harold Gumm and Harry
and Albert von Tilzer Professor
of Music at Columbia University
in New York, where he
has taught since 1982.
He was also then a guest
professor at the University
of Freiburg in Germany,
Yale University,
Princeton University, and the
University of Pennsylvania.
He has lectured on music
throughout the United States
and in England, France,
Spain, Germany, and China.
His writings have been
translated into French, German,
Spanish, Italian,
Japanese, and Chinese.
Professor Frisch is a specialist
in the music of composers
from the Austro-German sphere
in the 19th to 20th centuries,
ranging from Schubert
to Schoenberg.
Among many other things, he
has written numerous articles
and two books on Brahms, and
was the founding president
of the American Brahms
Society in 1983.
Professor Frisch's publications
on Schoenberg included the book
"The Early Works of Arnold
Schoenberg, 1893-1908"
and the edited volume
"Schoenberg and His World".
His book "German Modernism:
Music and the Arts" investigates
the relationships between music
and its cultural
context in Austria
and Germany during the
period of 1880 to 1915.
Professor Frisch serves as a
general editor of a new series
of period music histories
from W.W. Norton,
"Western Music in Context".
His volume in the series,
"Music in the Nineteenth
Century" was published
in the fall of 2012.
His book Arlen and Harburg's
"Over the Rainbow" appeared
in September of 2017, is part
of what I understand might
be an ongoing project.
Professor Frisch has twice won
the ASCAP-Deems Taylor Award
for his writings and he's
also been awarded fellowships
from the National
Endowment for the Humanities,
the Alexander von Humboldt
Foundation in Germany,
and the Center for
Scholars and Writers
at the New York Public Library.
Please join me in welcoming our
guest speaker Walter Frisch.
[ Applause ]
>> Walter Frisch: Thank
you very much David
for that kind introduction.
I want to first thank
the Library of Congress
for inviting me here today.
And it's been a pleasure-- I
think this is the fifth time
that I've had the privilege
of speaking at the Library
of Congress or in connection
with events dating back
to the very beginning
of my career.
David mentioned 1983 Brahms--
The American Brahms Society
was founded at a meeting
in the Library of Congress in
1983, at which I was present
and it's always been a
privilege and a pleasure
to not only be able to
participate in events like this,
but the research that I've
been able to do at the Library
of Congress over many
years on various topics,
most recently the
American popular song
of Harold Arlen and others.
And you know, I just want
to shout out, as a word,
not only to the values
and the resources
of this great institution but
to the people who work here
like David and the other
curators and librarians
and specialists that have, you
now, been so wonderfully helpful
over the years to me, myself,
and many, many researchers
and probably don't get
enough credit for that.
So anyway, that's a personal
note of my relationship
to this great institution.
So today, we're going
to be hearing a concert
that features two composers
of high modernism
in the 20th century.
When I say high modernism,
music that was understood
by the composers
themselves and the audiences
as very contemporary and very
often demanding and often
as seen as evolving or
having evolved from the music
of the later 19th century,
the sense of progressing
into modernism.
For Schoenberg and
Babbitt, this modernism
or this mission involved
among other things the serial
or twelve-tone method
of composition,
which was essentially invented
or developed by Schoenberg
in the 1920s as a new way of
organizing the pitch materials
of music without reference to
traditional scales or keys.
And Schoenberg was very proud
of this as were his pupils,
the famous comment that he
may or may not have made
about I have just managed
to ensure the hegemony
of German music for
the next hundred years,
Schoenberg supposedly said,
we're not sure whether
he said that.
And in the next generation
or a little bit beyond,
Babbitt became the greatest
exponent of the serial method
in the United States
beginning in the late 1940s.
So there's a kind of continuity
in a way across continents
between Schoenberg and Babbitt.
And the pictures you see here
were not chosen by me at random
because they show Schoenberg
and Babbitt in the classroom
with blackboards, if you
remember what those were,
working as teachers
and his instructors.
This was an important
part of their mission
and their priorities
as musicians.
They were both among the
most important teachers
of music composition and music
theory of the 20th century.
Schoenberg in Vienna, in Berlin,
and then later in Los Angeles
at USC and particularly UCLA
where this photograph was
most likely taken at UCLA.
You can even try and
follow the harmonic analysis
of a three chord there
on one of his classes.
And then Milton Babbitt,
of course at Princeton,
which where this photo was most
likely taken and then later
at Julliard in the
latter part of his career.
So Babbitt was one of
the first proponents
of Schoenberg's music
in the USA.
Babbitt had come to New York
in the early '30s to study
at NYU having given up
mathematics and the idea.
And he actually met
Schoenberg shortly
after Schoenberg
arrived in this country.
He's one of the first people--
He was introduced to him by
Lehman Engel, the conductor.
Schoenberg was at that time
living at the Ansonia hotel
in New York and Babbitt
got to meet him
and Babbitt was probably
one of the few people
who had really tried to
understand Schoenberg's music.
Babbitt often makes the
point that very few scores
of Schoenberg's music
were available or
but much more modern music
at that time and he managed
to get a hold of one piano
piece of Schoenberg's
and he was fascinated.
So they had very little personal
contact I think after that,
because Schoenberg moved to
Los Angeles for health reasons
and others and Babbitt
stayed on the east coast.
But both of them remained
active as not only as theorists
and composers but as writers.
And these two, Schoenberg's
writings were collected
in famous collection of essays
that he put together originally
in the early '50 or
1950 style and idea.
And later on in 2012, just
after Babbitt's death,
his essays were collected
in this.
And I would say these two
collections are among the most
important writings on
20th century music or--
and other music and certainly
among the most important
writings by composers.
They are classic collections.
It's really wonderful to
read Babbitt's essays put
together here.
He didn't necessarily-- or
maybe he consulted on it.
But the range going back
in time and his connection
to musical traditions was
as profound as Schoenberg's.
So I highly recommend
both books to you.
So Arnold Schoenberg's String
Quartets which we'll hear two
of today, quite remarkable, for
him as for many other composers
in the 20th century, say Bartok,
Shostakovich, Elliot Carter,
Milton Babbitt, the
quartet was a very important
and fruitful medium more than--
I would say more than any other
older genre including symphony
or even opera I would say
that the way this carries--
the String Quartet carries
over into the 20th
century is very striking.
And last night for those
of you who were here,
we heard how interesting the
String Quartet continues,
that Elliot Smith's and George
Lewis's work remarkable,
contemporary works
so that the medium
of the String Quartet
continues to offer possibilities
and fascination for composers.
So Schoenberg's published
for a quartet in his time
and then there's an earlier
work also on by the Library
of Congress in manuscript that--
I'm sorry, a student
work from 1897
which was only published later
very much in the idiom of Brahms
and Dvorak but a
quite a good work.
So of Schoenberg's published
quartets, the first two date
from his sort of total
period and the latter two are
in the twelve-tone idiom.
But it's sort of striking
when you think about it
that in some ways, in respect
to the norms or traditions
of the String Quartet genre,
the first two are more
radical in many respects.
And I'll discuss the
First Quartet in a moment,
which is in one long movement.
And for opus 10, the Second
Quartet, a voice is introduced
in the second-- third and fourth
movements, it's quite striking.
And the third and
Fourth String Quartets,
although they use the
twelve-tone method and are,
you know, very advance
in that way are in fact
in the standard form
movements of the genre
and they very much align with
the sort neoclassical movement
of the 1920s and '30s
that you might be familiar
with from Stravinsky and
[inaudible] and others.
And as such, Schoenberg's third
and Fourth Quartets are sort
of closer to the Haydn
and Beethoven tradition
of the quartet then are
the first two quartets.
And interesting, the reception
of these quartets mirrors
that in a way because
the first string--
both two first two String
Quartets caused disturbances,
even riots depending on how you
look at it at their premieres.
The First String Quartet was
premiered in 1907 and, you know,
people started hissing or
blowing on their house keys,
that was what you did in Vienna,
to express disapproval
at that concert.
And at that concert,
one of Schoenberg's early
supporters was there,
Gustav Mahler, who was very
prominent in Vienna as the head
of the Hofoper, the court opera
and was quite a, you know,
enthusiast or let's say a
supporter of Schoenberg.
And so Mahler, who
wasn't very tall,
nonetheless stood
up at this concert.
This is when opus
7 was premiered,
and said to somebody
behind him or around him,
"How dare you hiss
at this work?"
So this person actually
was a pretty good--
pretty good response
said, that's OK,
I hiss at your symphonies
too [laughter].
That apparently really happened.
And the Second String Quartet,
also in December of 1908,
caused a big ruckus in the
concert hall that lasted
at least for the first movement
and then quieted down a bit.
Whereas the Third String
Quartet, when it was premiered
in 1927, was actually kind of
a triumph for Schoenberg's.
He was called to the stage
many times or several times
and it was quite well
received, even though again,
this was in the sort of more
radical twelve-tone idiom.
So it's interesting in that
regard how Schoenberg's quartets
evolved across his
career in that respect.
So, the First String
Quartet of Schoenberg--
the first numbered String
Quartet, opus 7 from 1905,
I believe the manuscript is
out there for you to see is one
of the treasures of
the Library of Congress
that I think the
composer himself sold
to the library in the 1950.
And here is the first page
of this work from the time.
And just a few features of
it, this remarkable work
which last almost 50
minutes in performance,
so you're in for an experience
and you can't get up and go
to the bathroom because it's
one continuous movement,
it's highly contrapuntal,
the opening theme,
I don't know whether you
can see it or follow it,
is actually a composite
of three different lines.
And in a way, they are
all equally important
and then Schoenberg flips
them at various points
in the quartet, very linear
kind of writing and at least
to a very high level
of dissonance.
And Mahler famously--
or Schoenberg reports that
Mahler said about this,
Mahler is looking
through the score
of the First String Quartet
and says, this is amazing.
He said, I've written my self
scores and up to, you know,
30 or 40 parts and here's
a score with four lines
and I can barely read it or can
barely grasp it, said Mahler.
So even he was-- So as I say,
it's in one long
continuous movements
and interestingly
the piece divides--
it's very original and form, it
divides into four large sections
that align with the traditional
classical movement types.
So you have a sonata
form first movement,
[inaudible] a slow
movement and the finale.
But then interestingly,
Schoenberg's superimposes
on that design, a kind of
elements of a sonata form
in which the traditional
exposition, development,
recapitulation are
spread out across.
So like you got the
exposition of the first movement
and then part of the development
but you don't get the
recapitulation until later,
it's this very interesting
interwoven form.
And according to Leonard Stine,
his pupil when Schoenberg
would talk about this work
or teach it, he didn't even
needed a crib sheet so he could,
you know, sort of explain
where the different parts
of these two forms intersected
with each other because it's
so intricate, it's fascinating.
And the other thing is that
Schoenberg wrote a kind
of program or story
that allies the work.
So here's what Schoenberg
said about this quartet later
on when he was writing program
notes but he's referring
to he says, I abandoned
program-music,
which was in vogue at the time,
and turned in the direction
that was much more my own
that all the proceeding.
It was the First
String Quartet, Opus 7,
in which I combined
all the achievements
of my time including my own
such as the construction
of extremely large forms,
greatly expanded melodies based
on a richly moving harmony
and new chord progressions,
and a contrapuntal technique
that solved problems offered
by superimposed, individual
parts which moved freely
in more remote regions
of a tonality
and met frequently
in vagrant harmonies.
That was one of his
terms for this kind
of advanced harmonic language.
So it's this interesting
relationship between the lines
and the harmony, and
the way they line up.
But the fact that he says he
abandoned program-music is not
entirely true because in later
years he confessed ones--
I think in the class of
UCLA there was a private
but very definite
program for this quartet
and people didn't really
know what that meant.
And then when an editor
was preparing this quartet,
the first three of quartet
for a scholarly edition,
he came across something this,
so they're folded up inside
in German of course,
in the sketches materials
for the quartet.
And so this is what the
"program" is as its written
out I think by hand
and it's interesting,
it's not exactly a story
but it's like a series
of emotional states, revolt,
defiance, longing, rupture,
dejection, despair, comfort,
relieved, she and he, new,
outbreak, and you can see mild
disagreement, feeling new life,
and he gives it a
three-part program.
It's not clear exactly how
this aligns with peace itself,
although actually in the
sketches for the [inaudible],
we see feeling new life
so we know that that sort
of correspond to that.
Anyway, at the end, homecoming
joyful reception quite joy
at the entrance of
rest and harmony.
And indeed, it ends
in a very kind
of consonant and beautiful way.
So the fact that Schoenberg
has this program, you know,
shows how even in this kind
of radical work in many ways,
he is still very much
attached to and part
of these 19th century
traditions,
these ways of thinking
about music.
He had written "Pelleas
and Melisande",
he'd written "Verklarte
Nacht" "Transfigured Night",
he had written two big pieces
of program music before this.
But again, it's coming out of a
tradition of Strauss, Don Juan,
and [inaudible] whole tradition
that Schoenberg was still
very much a part of.
So it's interesting to have
this program and, you know,
the way he thought
about these works.
So the-- I'm not going to
play you much of this piece,
the First String
Quartet, just a little bit
because you'll be hearing
it obviously very shortly.
But I'll play you a little bit
from this is the first recording
of the Schoenberg's
String Quartet
which also a very
famous recording,
was done by the Kolisch
Quartet--
Rudolf Kolisch, you
see there on the right.
How do we know it's Rudolf
Kolisch besides the caption?
Notice anything about the
way he's holding his bow
and where he's a
left-handed violinist,
the most famous left handed
violinist, Rudolf Kolisch.
And whereas this
group, the Rose Quartet,
had premiered Schoenber's
first two quartets,
the Kolisch Quartet became
very much and associated
with Schoenberg's later work
and then Schoenberg's second
wife was Gertrud Kolisch,
Kolisch's sister.
So this recording was made
in Los Angeles in 1930s.
One of the Hollywood film
composers Alfred Newman would
study the Schoenberg, got
the musicians together
and rented the studio and it's
quite historic in that way even
if it's a little-- the
fidelity is not that great.
Anyway, here's a bit
of the opening theme
that you saw the three lines,
and then I'm just going to cut
to a later passage
which is very--
shows some of this linearity,
this-- it's like a fugue,
its basically a fugue where the
four voices enter successively.
But the thing is
sort of atonal fugue
because the themes
don't add up to any--
it's verging on atonality
because it doesn't add up at
that case to any kind of
clear harmonic coherence.
[ Music ]
And now that fugal
passage I mentioned.
[ Music ]
So that's among the most
dissonant music probably
that had been written
up to that time is 1905,
even before the later Mahler
and before Strauss's Elektra,
it's quite, quite
remarkable to have that.
So about the Third quartet,
here's a picture of Schoenberg
in the year of the Quartet No.3,
a famous photograph by Man Ray.
Schoenberg-- You know, everybody
who knew him or very often,
they spoke about his
eyes, his eyes, his gaze,
Schoenberg's eye, you know,
when you were in conversation
with him or in class with
him and you get something
at that gaze there, sort
of some ways are fearsome
looking modernist.
So the Third Quartet, which of
course the manuscript is also
here at the Library of Congress,
was written on a commission
from Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge,
of the Coolidge Auditorium.
He actually written the work
and then got the commission
so he dedicated to her the
work preceded the commission,
so to speak, by a little
bit but it's become
as the Fourth Quartet which
was commissioned and written
for Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge.
And I believe maybe you
can see that manuscript too
but he says Elizabeth Sprague
Coolidge commitment dedicated
to her.
So the Third Quartet, again,
is in the twelve-tone idiom
but very strongly neoclassical.
I mentioned it's very clearly
defined into four movements.
The first movement is
in traditional sonata
form in some respect.
The second movement is
a theme in variations,
another traditional
thing you would find
in Haydn and Beethoven.
The third movement is called the
Intermezzo but it has the form
of a kind of minuet
and trio, alternating.
And the finale is actually a
rondo, sections come back quite
in the manner of Haydn.
So this is very much part of--
and people have often said
that with Schoenberg working
in a fairly new language
still of the twelve-tone idiom
that he-- the external
forms he made, so to speak,
as traditional as possible
so that audiences, you know,
would have something
to grab onto.
I'm oversimplifying.
But if you-- the first fully
twelve-tone work is the piano
Suite Opus 25 is like a Baroque,
a suite of Baroque piano
pieces and, you know, Gavotte,
you know, pavane-- not pavane
but various dance forms.
So again, Neo-Baroque
in that case.
So that was the very
characteristic of that.
And yet even here, Schoenberg
sort of still thinks back
to some of the, you might say,
programmatic associations.
I know that David quotes
this in your program but two
that you'll have today
where Schoenberg wrote again
in the notes or line or
notes around this time,
"As a little boy I was tormented
by a picture of a scene
of a fairytale 'The Ghost
Ship', geist or something,
whose captain had been nailed
through the head to the topmast
by his rebellious crew.
I am sure this was not the
"program" of the first movement
of the Third String Quartet.
But it might have
been, subconsciously,
a very gruesome premonition
which caused me
to write this work, because
as often as I thought
about this movement,
the first movement,
that picture came to my mind."
And indeed, the movement
is dominated
by this repeated figure,
ta, ta, ta, ta, ta, ta,
sort of could mean many
things but like I said called
up this picture in
Schoenberg's mind.
So again, very much thinking
in a 19th century way
about this sort of
possibly programmatic aspect
of music of his own music.
So, we have-- when Schoenberg
wrote in the twelve-tone method,
he often helped himself with
creating these row tables
that he would-- this is from
the Arnold Schoenberg Center
in Vienna.
And Schoenberg loved making
contraptions and, you know,
he design playing
cards and various kind
of mechanical things, toys
and things for his children
but also practical
things like this.
So here is one of his little--
you know, with the bar
that can slide up and down
to show him the thing.
And interesting you
see at the top there T,
even at this stage T seems
to represent the word
tonic or tonika in German.
So that means sometimes he
called it principle form
of the row but the fact
that he's still thinking
of these rows, even though
they are not really related
to tonality as the tonika,
as the tonic, the home key
in a way, shows that, you know,
you're sort of attached
to that tradition.
So he could move around
these little things.
And at the top, you see the row,
the 12-note ordering
of the form for this.
And here's that later row table
that he prepared while he was
in the United States for
this Third String Quartet.
And here he calls it the basic
set and he numbers the pitches 1
through 12 and then he
gives you inversions.
And what's interesting
about this String Quartet--
the Third String Quartet is that
he uses three different forms
of the row but the five--
first five notes are
the same for each one.
So G, E, D sharp, A, C if you
can read, but then 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 11, 12 changed.
So, what he's done here is
he gives you 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 and then an alternate
version of 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11,
12 over the one, two,
three and fourth column,
and then on the fifth column
yet another ordering
of the last pitches.
And in the fourth column there,
with the parenthesis underneath,
he shows what the ordering
was at the beginning
in the first row, 6, 8, 7,
11, those were the orderings
in the basic set there.
And indeed, it's fascinating
the way he works that out
and it shows that it's
really just a sort of query
of notes and relationships.
So what he does-- I'll
play this in the second
but if you can read the music,
he's got this five-note--
it's eight notes but five
pitches, "pam, pam, pam, pam,
pam, pam, pam, pam,
pam", not singing it right.
There are notes one
through five of the row.
And then six and seven--
interestingly, six
and seven are here.
That would be E sharp here,
whereas this is 8, 9, 10, 11,
12, so he forms the
accompaniment,
this constantly repeating
accompaniment of one
through five and
that stays the same.
Notice it keeps repeating.
And then the other notes
form a melody above.
So there's so many different
relationships that he can pull
out of that, so that's why
he separates six and seven.
Anyway, this is what that sounds
like, you know, with the sailor
or the captain nailed
to the mast or whatever,
but it's very interesting.
Where is my sound?
[ Music ]
And so, even from what you've
heard, I think you can hear
that Schoenberg maintains
actually
to some extent the
distinction between secondary
or accompaniment figures and
melodic lines that is part
of the tradition of Haydn,
Beethoven, Brahms, and so on.
But it now has a different
framework, not tonal anymore
but based on the sort of
ordering of the 12-note row
and that sort of runs
throughout this piece.
And so-- And of course,
you know, Schoenberg--
many of Schoenberg's pupils and
disciples spent a lot of time
as if many generation since
sort of tracing out the row
in every movement of Schoenberg
counting the notes, you know,
this is one, two,
three, four, five.
And his brother-in-law,
Rudolf Kolisch did this
or I don't know, he wasn't--
yeah, I guess he was his
brother-in-law about that time.
For the Third Quartet and sent
this to Schoenberg, his analysis
of the piece, and Schoenberg
this is a famous response,
I think it's also in
your program note.
Schoenberg writes to Kolisch
sort of admonishingly,
"You have worked out the
series in my String Quartet.
You must have gone to a
great deal of trouble,
and I don't think I'd have
had the patience to do it.
But do you think any one's
any better off for knowing it?
I can't quite see it that way.
My firm belief is that
for a composer who doesn't
yet know quite his
way about the use
of the series it may give some
idea of how to set about it--
a purely technical
indication of the possibility
of getting something
out of the series.
But this isn't where the
aesthetic qualities reveal
themselves, or, if
so, only incidentally.
I can't utter too many warnings
against overrating
these analyses,
since after all they only lead
to what I have always been dead
against, seeing how it is done
or as I have always have helped
people to see what it is!
I can't say it often enough,
my works are twelve-tone
compositions,
not 12-note compositions."
So this is, you know, again,
Schoenberg repeating this.
This is music.
These are composition
and the series anymore
than if you took a piece,
you know, the Eroica Symphony
and talk about the key of E
flat major endlessly, you know,
Beethoven would say, well,
E flat major is not what my
Eroica Symphony is about,
it's about many other things,
instrumentations and the history
and so forth, so it sort of
analogous to that really.
So which brings us to Milton
Babbitt, it's somewhat true
of Babbitt as well the idea that
you shouldn't only be listening
to the serial possibility.
Babbitt often struggle
against the reception
and perception of his works.
And arguably he was
doing so in an era--
post-war era concert world
where it was even more polarized
with people unwilling
to a very small group
of new music fanatics
and then other people
who were not interested in this
repertory or in these concerts.
And in one of the most
famous-- infamous essays really,
of the later 20th century,
appearing in High
Fidelity magazine,
Milton Babbitt wrote this
essay about this phenomenon
and it was entitled "Who
Cares if You Listen?"
Which actually it turns
out was not his own choice
of title at all.
The editor put it on
but also surrounded
in this forbidding black.
And this famous article from
1958 from High Fidelity,
Babbitt sort of arguing, well,
if you really can't take the
time to understand this music,
then you shouldn't be
listening to it and, you know,
we have to sort of retreat in
a way into the ivory tower.
And so later on, he--
his own preferred title
for this essay was "The
Composer as Specialist"
and in his collected writings,
that's how it appears.
So what he says is,
Babbitt, "I dare suggest
that the composer
would do himself
and his music an immediate
and eventual service by total,
resolute, and voluntary
withdrawal
from this public world to
one of private performance
and electronic media, with
its very real possibility
of complete elimination of
the public and social aspects
of musical composition.
Very radical.
By so doing, the separation
between the domains would be
defined beyond any possibility
of confusion of categories,
and the composer would be free
to pursue a private life of
professional achievement,
as opposed to a public life
of unprofessional
compromise and exhibitionism.
The various institutes
of advanced research
and the large majority
of foundations had disregarded
contemporary music's need
for the means of survival.
Granting to music the
position accorded other arts
and sciences promises the sole
substantial means of survival
for the music I have
been describing.
If this music is not supported,
the whistling repertory
of the man in the street
will be little affected,
the concert-going activity
of the conspicuous consumer
of musical culture will
be little disturbed.
But music will cease to
evolve, right because for him
and for Schoenberg the idea
the music had to evolve, and,
that important sense,
will cease to live."
So again and, you know, to view
this sympathetically in a way,
Babbitt is saying that, you
know, after all the humanities
and the arts and science get
support whereas composers don't
get that kind of foundation
or university support.
And indeed, the university
is the only place
and that's true today, basically
where a composer can have
that kind of freedom
and level of, yeah,
ability to do what he wants.
So, a very-- and
this is certainly one
of the most famous essays of
the later 20th century music,
a very powerful statement
that probably alienated
Babbitt even more
from the public rather.
But Babbitt-- So the
question is his music is--
treats uses a serial method
not only in terms of pictures
but in terms of other
dimensions.
Sometimes dynamics,
rhythm, meter.
So it's applying-- it sort of
goes beyond Schoenberg in a way.
And Babbitt was asked,
can you hear this stuff?
Can you hear-- Or
how dependent is it?
Like Schoenberg is saying,
how dependently is it
on being able to
hear these things?
And here's his response
in an interview.
You do need to hear it but--
>> Milton Babbitt: I have to
learn to hear it [inaudible],
you learn it informally
as well as formally.
I'm not saying you take
ear-training courses,
but when you grow into the
music, after all, all you have
to hear are intervals,
the fundamental building
blocks of any music.
When Stravinsky-- you know,
Stravinsky showed tremendous
insight in that respect.
When somebody said, how
could you have deserted us?
How could you become
such an infidel?
Well, I shouldn't use that word.
How could you have done this?
How could you have deserted us
and become a twelve-tone,
a serial composer?
He said, but I've always
composed with intervals.
And that was remarkable
because he recognized something
that very few people, even
who regarded themselves
as being quite friendly
to twelve-tone music.
We're not talking about notes.
We're not talking
about pitch classes.
We're talking mainly about the
relationship between the two;
that marvelous relation
called an interval
which is unique almost
entirely to the perception
of sound and nothing else.
So he certainly used them
in a particularly singular
and remarkable way.
>> Walter Frisch:
Now he's talking
about Stravinsky
there at the turn.
And, you know, you
might say, OK, well,
you can hear those intervals
but, you know, can the rest
of us always hear
those intervals?
You know that Babbitt can
with your amazing ear.
So-- But you sort of
see where he is coming
from in that position.
And on the other hand,
Babbitt, you know,
as you can already tell
maybe from that interview,
he had sort of a
whimsical sense of humor
and quite [inaudible]
personality.
And most of the titles for
his works are puns in one way
or another, Semi-Simple
Variations,
All Set for jazz ensemble,
Sextets, Playing for time,
About Time, It Takes Twelve
to Tango, Transfigured Notes,
Joy of More Sextets
which we'll hear today,
Whirled Series, get it?
Play It Again, Sam, None But
the Lone Flute, Around the Horn.
I saw one septet but
equal the other day too.
So the very individual
titles that he gave
to his pieces across his career.
Now, what you'll hear
today is actually one
of Babbitt's longest pieces,
almost was 25 minutes long.
And it's not an easy listen
in a way, I will admit,
having spent some time.
It divides into two very
large sections but you might--
and the way to tell when that's
happening is there's a big piano
solo in the middle.
It's for piano and violin
about 12 minutes in.
You got a long piano solo
and then begins Part 2.
And beyond that, there's
all this use of color,
use of register,
use of dynamics,
but not traditional sections,
not traditional melody
and accompaniment by any means.
So use of various means to
kind of move from one section
to the other, but again not
in a way that sonata form
or anything like that.
What I would show here briefly,
and I've cherry-picked
my examples, of course,
but in a way what Babbitt
is doing is not so different
or you can see it from a
tradition and I've chosen
of works for say
violin and piano.
So here's the third movement
of Brahms' third violin sonata.
And obviously a total work
but you can have some pretty
radical harmonic gestures
and usual progressions along
with the very restricted
motivic language that Brahms,
like just a motive of two or
three notes that gets repeated
and the melody sort of dissolves
into these little fragments
that in many ways points
ahead to the 20th century.
[ Music ]
It's a very special musical
language that, you know,
is part of the late 19th
century but it's really--
and then, you know,
20 years later
or so [inaudible] petty much
dissolves this traditional
melody plus accompaniment into
a more of an explanations--
exploration, sorry, of the
colors and the possibilities
between violin and piano.
Many different techniques used.
So, this is 1910, this
is already 108 years ago.
Can get to it here.
[ Music ]
And with Babbitt, I'll just
play a short excerpt of it.
It's really-- If you view that
sort of evolutionary metaphor,
really is part of this tradition
but a later manifestation
of the evolution of exploring
these different sonorities,
dialog, you might say exchanges
between violin and piano.
[ Music ]
Gestures are much more
extreme and fragmented,
but really in some
ways, not that different
from the [inaudible] from
75 years or however earlier.
So, that's one way to
sort of listen for it.
A few final remarks, Babbitt and
Schoenberg have this reputation,
you know, as-- which they
partly cultivated as sort
of these modernist writers,
a very difficult music.
But both had a lot of interest
in-- or both had interest in
and respect for popular music,
popular music culture
of their time.
And it comes out somewhat in
their music but also in the way
in which they expressed
themselves about this music.
And I want to-- Sorry.
So I don't know how
many of you know
that Stephen Sondheim
studied with Milton Babbitt.
Here's a little bit from
a wonderful documentary
which explains this
relationship in ways
that I think are quite moving.
>> Stephen Sondheim:
You changed my life.
You taught me what
music is about.
>> Milton Babbitt: Actually I
haven't the slightest idea why
he came to me.
I really don't.
I mean I was hardly
a hustle [inaudible].
This was 1952.
He said it was '51,
[inaudible] 1952.
I have no idea how he coming
out of Williams College
whose closest associates
in music were Oscar Hammerstein
and others [inaudible].
Well, he came to study with
me and there was no question
of coming to study musical
comedy or any of that,
he didn't even know I had
the interest or any concern.
He wanted to do script
counterpoint,
species counterpoint, he want
to do the implications
[inaudible] analysis.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> We met once week and we would
spend I'd say probably three
to four hours together.
And the first hour we
spent in analyzing songs.
[ Music and Singing ]
I taught at Oxford
about four years ago.
And the class wanted a
little musical analysis
and I gave Milton's analysis
of "All the Things You Are".
It's not only accurate
but it's eye-opening.
[ Music and Singing ]
>> Milton Babbitt: Kern
was the profoundly most
original songwriter.
There were no two
songs really alike.
And every sense of the word
his songs were crafted.
>> Walter Frisch: You know,
that's where it cuts off.
So he's talking about
Jerome Kern.
Babbitt and Sondheim
and that song was
"All the Things You Are".
So he had great admiration.
And in his early days,
Babbitt wrote show songs.
I believe they are actually
here at the Library of Congress,
some of the kind of
the pop songs he wrote.
So again, this was
part of who he was
and what he was interested in.
And the same is true
for Arnold Schoenberg.
Schoenberg, when he
lived in Los Angeles,
became pretty good friends
with George Gershwin.
And they played tennis together.
They did other things.
You see here a picture
of Gershwin painting his
portrait of Arnold Schoenberg.
And if you go across
the hall after,
you can see the wonderful
Gershwin room over there.
You can see some other paintings
that Gershwin did, self-portrait
and then a wonderful portrait of
Jerome Kern, the composer that--
and here he is painting his
Arnold Schoenberg portrait.
And for his part, Schoenberg
really admired Gershwin.
When Gershwin died in 37,
I guess in Los Angeles,
they asked a number of people
to make comments on the radio.
Schoenberg has an essay also in
style and idea about Gershwin.
And here's what Schoenberg
said about George Gershwin.
I've transcribed it because
his accent is rather thick.
>> Arnold Schoenberg:
George Gershwin was one
of these rare kind of musicians
to whom music is not a matter
of more or less ability.
Music to him was
the air he breathed,
the food which nourished him,
the drink that refreshed him.
Music was what made him feel
and music was the
feeling he expressed.
Directness of this kind is
given only to great men.
And there is no doubt that
he was a great composer.
What he has achieved was
not only to the benefit
of a national American music
but also a contribution
to the music of the whole world.
In this meaning I want to
express the deepest grief
for the deplorable
loss to music.
>> Walter Frisch: So Schoenberg
and Babbitt, high modernists
who nonetheless had
great admiration
for you might say soft spot
for the great American
song tradition as well.
So all in there and I'm happy to
take some question if you want.
And thank you for listening.
[ Applause ]
>> Didn't Babbitt at one
time write on a commission
for the [inaudible]
orchestra who said
that they were not
able to play it?
And there were some
consideration
about they wanted
their money back?
>> Walter Frisch: Yeah,
that piece, I forgot,
"Transfigured Notes" yeah, yeah.
>> What happened with that?
>> Walter Frisch: I
guess did they-- yes.
>> Record the [inaudible]
recorded it.
>> Walter Frisch:
Of course he did.
And in that documentary which
you can find on YouTube,
there are some discussion
of that
and it shows Babbitt sitting
at rehearsals for that piece,
I think and-- or just after
and complaining that, you know,
the conductor hadn't really
prepared or, you know,
complaining that this piece
is not unplayable but people,
you know, have to learn-- know
how to read notes and stuff
like that, they read
this and some stuff.
>> I was doing a
visiting composer series
for Peabody Conservatory
when I was in school there
and I had the opportunity
to spend some time
with Milton Babbitt, and we
went out drinking and he had
like the Rusty Nail, it
was a drink that he had
and just given a talk in
seminar which went miles
above everybody's head.
And he had things on the board,
I remember, equations look
like mathematical equations.
I didn't have the slightest idea
so as we were talking he said--
and we had a couple of
drinks, he said, well,
what did you think of the talk?
I said if you want to know
I had to tell you, it was--
you could have been
double talking,
to which he started laughing,
had a great laugh about that.
The man just had
an incredible way
of talking, but so brilliant.
>> Walter Frisch:
Indeed, indeed.
>> And the other thing with
Schoenberg, didn't he say once
that he was not a slave
to the twelve-tone.
If there was a note he wanted
instead of one in the row,
he would just put it
in, he wouldn't feel--
>> Walter Frisch: Yes.
And more and more as his
career went on he did that.
I mean, even already
in that Third Quartet,
it's very flexible again because
it's not you read in textbooks
or in, you know, Wikipedia
or whatever, you know,
you're not supposed
to repeat any note
until all 12 have sounded
but that's not the case.
And then in the later
movements of the Third Quartet,
he's combining them
harmonically.
And so yeah, absolutely,
there's a lot of--
yeah, it's a compositional
tool not a template at all.
>> Because he has
feeling of being so rigid
but he wasn't actually.
>> Walter Frisch:
No, it was never.
I don't think so, yeah.
>> I thank-- Can you hear?
>> Walter Frisch: Yes.
>> OK, thanks.
Thank you.
I came in late so I
may be asking some
about Schoenberg you covered.
Thanks for making the
links between them
and the pop song composers
I'd like to tell the story too
which you probably know that,
the College Quartet did
the first recordings
of the Schoenberg Quartets--
>> Walter Frisch: Yes.
>> -- in the '30s and Gershwin
was one of the major financiers
of those recordings, so
there was mutual admiration.
>> Walter Frisch:
Absolutely, absolutely, yeah.
>> And found a brief
interview excerpt with Babbitt
on I was looking for it
last night, couldn't find it
but where he really tells a
story of meeting Hindemith
and it was kind of
an improbable meeting
and probably the first words
out of Hindemith's mouth
when he saw Babbitt was,
you look like a twelve-tone
composer.
[ Laughter ]
And the documentary on
Babbitt really is wonderful.
Big question maybe don't try to
go into deep detail but I'd be--
what is your perspective
on sort of the--
do you think the
twelve-tone or serial method
or approaches has much
influence in today's music?
Is it mainly in Europe and
not so much in United States?
>> Walter Frisch: I think its
role has diminished and a lot--
what composers are doing is a
lot different in many respects
and not so much pitch-based
anymore but more, you know,
timbre-based spectralist
and or rhythm, yeah,
maybe some of the--
some European composers.
But I think that-- you
know, and some people argue
that the apparent supremacy
of the twelve-tone method
was never really supremacy
that all along, you know, there
were people doing other kinds
of music, there were
Rachmaninov's
and [inaudible] [inaudible] and,
you know, Samuel Barbers both
in Europe and here and that
Benjamin Brittens and--
but that in the post-- and with
probably because, you know,
again, Babbitt wrote a lot
and was very influential
in the Princeton School built
this up, some would say,
then the German publication
[inaudible] built it up--
that it was, you know, more
universal than it ever was even
in the '30s, '40s, and '50s.
But yeah, I would say it's
diminished now, I don't know.
I admit that I don't follow
the contemporary music scene
that much or at least the
part that I follow say based
at Columbia or New York City,
that's really not part of it.
I mean people study it, I think,
but they don't use it, but yeah.
>> Well, according to respond to
your question a little indirect
but we heard [inaudible]
same thing basically.
Schoenberg once said that
he didn't want people
to analyze his techniques.
He wanted them to
whistle his melodies.
>> Walter Frisch: Yes,
yes, that's a famous--
>> Now that's challenging and
that gets to a Babbitt quote,
Babbitt was almost
endlessly quotable.
He said Schoenberg
found out how it feels
to have history leave you ahead.
>> Walter Frisch: That's
good, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you very much, yeah.
Yes.
>> Two comments.
The Babbitt, his feeling of
non-compromise took me back
to memory of hearing in New
York City in the mid '70s.
I think it was playing for time.
I don't think it had
been published yet.
And he was doing something
with the dance group,
could have been [inaudible]
I'm not sure,
but it was in a very small
room and it was like packed
with people from stem to stern
and a horseshoe and
then the group.
And really-- And he was
there and it really was one
of the most intense experiences
I have ever remembered.
So I think there is
something about that.
I think it's the intensity
that he didn't want
to leak out by compromise.
>> Walter Frisch: Yeah.
I think that's-- yeah.
>> Yeah. And the second one
is this thing about Stravinsky
and his neoclassical the Third
Symphonies and the criticism
that he wasn't being true to
Schoenberg and his method.
And in actuality,
Stravinsky came back and said,
I'm trying to follow
Schoenberg's method
to the letter.
And he was being
criticized for his lack
of repetitive and freedom of it.
So I'm wondering if perhaps he
needed Schoenberg to move away
from some of the early roots of,
you know, the "dom, dom, dom,
dom, dom", the repetitive
rhythmic style and--
>> Walter Frisch: For Stravinsky
to move away from that, yeah.
>> And to kind of free him
up into having a structure
but freeing up the
rhythmic aspect of that.
>> Walter Frisch: That's
an interesting theory.
I mean I do think that-- I
mean Babbitt has a good point
about Stravinsky or anybody.
Aaron Copland, when he turned
into the twelve-tone method.
They always sound like
themselves, Stravinsky,
if you listen to
Agon, the ballet,
it sounds like Stravinsky,
Copland's Nonet or some
of the later works that
use twelve-tone method.
They never sound-- which, you
know, again, sort of proves
if you will that the twelve-tone
method is not a style
or it's not-- you
know, it's a tool
and Stravinsky will still
sound like Stravinsky.
And you know, I mean I do
think those rhythmic aspects
of Stravinsky may be not
as intense as in "The Rite
of Spring" but he's
interested in rhythmic ostinati
and shaping things with that.
It's still there but
yeah, it can be modified
with the twelve-tone system.
I mean it supposedly,
famously, you know,
he waited until Schoenberg
died until '51
and then he started writing
serial music, you know,
when they were both sort of, you
know, competitors if you will
or at least rivals of some
sort in Los Angeles in the '30s
and '40s and '50s or, you know,
up until Schoenberg's death
and Stravinsky felt
more liberated
to try the twelve-tone method.
Yeah.
>> David Plylar: I think--
Sorry, I think we're
about out of time.
So I just want to throw out
there that there is quite a lot
of stylistic variety in serial
music that is definitely
out there that I want you
to explore and consider
as you consider in looking
at this type of music.
But there's not just one
particular method that's
followed, you know, to this day
and things like that, you know,
it's often a misconception.
>> Walter Frisch: Yeah,
anymore than pieces
in E flat major sound is
different from each other,
you know, as the
Eroica Symphony and--
you know, thinking other E
flat, can't come up with it.
But thank you.
Anyway, yeah, so I think
that's a good point,
it doesn't dictate a style.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.